please welcome the empire the icon the
one and only christina tosin
um i am so excited because i mean it's
just like i i
i can't believe the empire you built
it's really amazing and as someone who
knows and respects business what you
have built christina
is just like oh my gosh really thank you
okay so here's i thought it could be fun
to
so we've gone out and hung out at great
restaurants together but we've never
actually baked together no so i brought
you
um
one of our best-selling cakes it's it's
one of our iconic cakes it's the
birthday cake it's the cake that like
reminds you of your childhood but that
we've deconstructed you know we do all
the like outside the box stuff how do
you deconstruct what makes something so
um like sticky
yes a nostalgic and how do you bake it
up with fresh perspective well i think
we're gonna try something that we've
never done on the show which is like
you're gonna direct me are you ready for
that i'm your actor i'm your student i'm
your clay mold me okay i'm all yours
christina i am all yours you're all mine
okay so the birthday cake it we don't
frost it on the sides because there is
so much like thought and emotion and
process into it we don't want to hide it
behind frosting i like frosting just as
much as anyone else but that's why we
don't frost the sides of our cake i hear
that why annihilate all the hard work
you've done also i just bring it up also
i just want to say frosting the sides of
a cake perfectly is a very hard thing
setting you up for success good okay
great okay so um birthday cake i already
baked the actual cake sponge but you're
gonna cut out rounds
that's right we cut this is a six inch
cake and we make it at all the bakeries
we ship it to doorsteps all across the
country
and this is it for good days for bad
days for birthdays and everything in
between exactly really training so
that's the round you can use this pull
it out the palette knife
yes you got it bring it on over here
boom
you got i'm so impressed look at you i'm
about to get through it
and then you give it exactly a little
pat down from here so we take the cake
soak are you ready for this this you
have to make into a perfume i feel like
this is right up your alley so you've
got the cake sponge then we soak it by
making a little bit of birthday cake
soak are you ready to smell this it's a
little bit of clear vanilla extract oh
my god it smells like the bottom of a
cereal i mean it's like fruit it's a
little bit of like just get a little in
here right it would make a perfect
perfect so a little bit of cake soak
that's moisture and flavor and then you
ready for this i love that you're like
let's you would you would thrive in a
kitchen so you do birthday frosting we
spread that around i'm going to do that
i take you ready for this the cheapest
spoon and i use it as my palette knife
when i don't have a palette knife that's
you know just in case it's in the washer
i love that you just bent the necklace
come on girl power
um some birthday crumbs and then you're
going to come on top with another cake
round look at you go
true true i'm true
true
true
you got it you got this
oh my god just nestle it in it's sort of
like gluing layers of cake in between
frosting okay and then
you do a little bit of frosting on top
okay
and then once the frosting on top gets
smoothed out we throw it in the fridge
the freezer to set all the layers but
you get in there with your spoon yeah
[Music]